hey guys Ryan right here this is where
you say your name oh okay I'm sorry
that's where you go and you speak it
right now yeah go for it
hey itself from soz real thoughts that's
right got a youtuber on the channel with
me here today she is a movie critic who
tends to do independent flicks right yes
occasionally does a trailer reaction or
two and she goes to film festival stuff
and kind of did a little vlogs about it
yeah there we go
promoted you right up front the video
BAM make you look good we're gonna watch
the trailer today for a movie called
Cinderella no idea what it's about
I never ready you do just kidding I
don't know Cinderella do you not like
Cinderella
you can't realize I love the original
it's just like excessive to make another
one do I might I don't know the original
with brandy was so good oh yes
no I do ABC they know is it's amazing
Whoopi Goldberg Whoopi Goldberg I
I love Randy where is she yeah what the
[ __ ] having her and Whoopi go I'm of
course kidding so I know
Cinderella comes from that Disney [ __ ]
I like Cinderella story I mean it goes
along the lines with all the other I
don't know I'm trying to tell you guys
yeah we all know that Cinderella's a bus
trip rate a PG 4 miles them Meg they
should make it like n c---seventeen I
watch it that we'll see you
have courage and be kind you merely be
your stepmother you have two lovely
sisters to keep company so I'll know as
far away as I may be that your thee sake
why don't you prefer to eat me the work
is done Ella don't even call me madam
you all right miss what did he clear
never mind what they call me I'm sorry
it's not your doing no yours either I'll
bet those eyes are you again this here I
you know you have more kindness in a
little finger than most people possess
in their whole body ha ha this would be
an insult to take it to the panelists
rest in peace grounds
what you shall not go to the ball babies
mate why are you crying
who are you
that's better hi oh my god
ha
yeah please nice
nice
face class and you find that really
comfortable now if you could please
shall go to the ball
are we working here believe me they were
looking at you
when there is kindness there is goodness
but where there is goodness there is
magic
I have to see her again
are you looking for this
what are your real tough
I don't like Cinderella I don't know
like Disney because they like constantly
promote like your prince charming like
he's not out there guys he just like
doesn't exist and I don't like to watch
things that kind of tell that to our
like little girls that there's hope when
there's not but Kate Blanchet and uh
Helena Bonham Carter is in this so I'm
kind of like really really stoked about
it and that's why the only reason why I
watched the movie but other than that
it's like this story has been told so
many times I don't need to see it again
mm-hmm and then wish for positive things
to happen and yeah yeah visually it's
like oh my god it's stunning no visually
it looks great production design looks
great but I'm like okay I wasn't a fan
of the actual movie
Snow White and the Huntsman but I liked
the idea of taking this story and kind
of telling it really differrent yeah
this looks like alive adaptation of the
cartoon you know exactly the same it's
like the whole trailer to me was like
saying hey remember how great Cinderella
is just make money yeah cuz like if you
don't know the Cinderella story
that's the whole story you're right
there and why don't you see like the 90s
version instead of this one I don't
might as well or the one with Hilary
Duff remember that one totally forgot I
prefer the brandy one that was a lot
more fun I can read this I'm singing in
there oh nice it was like yeah like that
it was like some yeah pop-influenced I
don't know it seems very like over like
just try it overly done yeah I mean it
doesn't look as anything fresher
offering and I'm like why'd you take the
mice out of talking I like the one them
I spoke I really did and they made it
then like live-action yeah well I mean
minding me and live-action I just wanted
to speak oh they might they should you
never know I'm just saying if you guys
are watching this in this film is still
in post make them talk yeah there are
some funny voices in there they really
should have just made it like extreme
they should just change some they could
have made it a really dark picture to be
honest this is a woman about [ __ ]
like she gets thrown into this family
and they just abuse the hell out of her
like ever after that was like kind of
like there was on a dark yeah there was
like real danger but this is like
where's my prince charming like I gotta
find her like I have to and Prince
Charming seems so [ __ ] cliche like
blue eyes seriously seriously
there's like one out of a million out
there you know one black guy out like
yes yeah thanks Edie now we're donating
to a charity to support more black
people in this world and more films we
just need it okay what I want to be one
I mean the film looks and looking at
honestly I have no interest in much okay
well I'm like if enough people want me
to watch it and I watch it and I going
with an open mind to like even if a
trailer looks like [ __ ] to me I'll watch
it with a complete open mind and I'm
sure there's gonna be some fun stuff
about it I don't think it's just for us
like I got kind of chills cuz it was
like really well done and I was like I
can feel it but I've seen this and it
should pop it's obviously targeted to
like other people well just from the
trailer alone like I say it's just the
[ __ ] trailers I don't know but like
it looks like you're trying to capture
like this Wonder and fantasy but I'm
like I don't feel wondering yeah I feel
like I'm just looking I'm observing
something but I don't feel like this is
a world of all this craziness and mode
they want your emotions to be flying you
know like I'm a little emotional you did
yeah like oh my god
but what which part I don't know Paulo
and the music kicked in cuz they trick
you like that make sure you yeah music a
minute guys I'm in it I'm invested I
mean don't get me wrong I'm sure there's
gonna be some fun stuff like I'm sure a
cape on show will be [ __ ] awesome
milwaukee's she looks scary she really
does and Hellena
um how'd you say it beau hem Carter
those blow oh I'm really bad with
pronouncing things
it's pronunce announcing yeah yeah
that's my English is just like up off
all the time so it's all the Timmy
and just say no Prince Charming is real
you're looking right at me I'm talking
about me I'm Prince Charming
hey guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
where we keep it REE L real and guess
what
she's got some thoughts so does those
real unfiltered thoughts uh-huh
check that [ __ ] out subscribe to her
Channel yeah promotion one Sanchez hey
Ryan can I get a shout out big fan of
the channel yeah Juan Sanchez you could
totally get a shout-out I'm glad you're
a big fan of the channel but I want you
to prove how big of a fan you really are
I want you to leave on so Channel
a really nice compliment whoa about her
looks not about my love mainly her looks
not about my hey you know I want you to
talk about the types of fantasies you
would have about her share it on her
channel I will find you and she will
Paul Bert any chance of a shout out
someday sure Paul Bert that's your real
name that sucks
sounds like paul blart no God watch it
oh dude that is a classic it is like
cinematic history you know we always see
movies about cops clearly but never
about the mall class they're so slow
anyway Paul Bert is that what you do for
a living Paul
are you a mall cop cos you could be a
good mall cop based off your little
thumb at a nail here mister this Amster
hey guys I honestly love your channel
and I was wondering if I could get a
shout-out thanks I want you a new name
that's what I want you to do okay and is
that you and your thumbnail I was
expected I'm going to answer but videos
filmed then post later what's her type
of guy if you're into guys I don't know
what you're into guys girls doesn't
matter
I do like geeks
you do like geeks he's a gamer oh nice
nice he does games apparently do
something with your life I thought you
were nothing
geek huh you smile from cheek to cheek
you like to take long leaks sometimes by
the creek Wow you want to speak
sometimes you play hide and seek I wish
I could beat box right now no dude you
should but your be Fox is weak oh my god
I know impressive isn't it gamer geek